at this manufacturing facility in Salem
New Hampshire machines are assembling
hardwood this is the aerial antenna
we've found a great design we did a lot
of work on that optimize it and achieve
great performance for the size we have
Ariel gave us an inside look at the busy
factory where its final product comes
together the product that's
revolutionising the way we watch
broadcast TV and you see how the
technology works it's different than
using old-fashioned rabbit ears area
rents each antenna to an individual
subscriber but the antennas aren't
mounted on top of the subscribers TV
instead they're stacked on boards they
then slide into a box that can
accommodate five to seven thousand
antennas and mounted on rented rooftops
and cities across the country the
antenna sends the TV signal to a
transcoder and then a DVR allowing you
to stream online and also pause rewind
and record a standard master antenna big
antenna or a cable company takes all the
spectrum and pushes it down the wire to
you whether you as the customer wants it
or not this is a model which you'd only
listening to what you want
what is the capability of what you you
can you can make me fat oh we've not
even come close slightly we can
manufacture just a huge numbers many
more than ten times I live for within
the field already easily area plans to
operate in 22 cities by the end of this
year and has built the business to
accommodate whatever level of demand
comes its way we can deploy it for 5000
customers and turn a profit on that and
then as demand grows we can grow with
that as opposed to the conventional
model that says I'm gonna build it out
and hope they come those are very analog
business models that I don't think are
capable of being successful in today's